[Applause]
good afternoon everyone very pleased to
welcome you to two Colombian tulo
library I'm David Madigan executive vice
president for Arts and Sciences and Dean
of the Faculty of Arts and Sciences here
at Columbia and I'm very pleased to
welcome you I want to right at the
outset just take a moment to thank our
co-sponsor for this event the Committee
on global thought and I know there are a
few people here from from the CGT as we
call it around here tonight this
afternoon we welcome the Honorable sure
bahador dooba prime minister of Nepal
Nepal the Nepal of Legend is a
mountainous Kingdom containing eight of
the world's ten highest peaks it's a
small nation situated between two
powerhouse neighbours India and China
and it is a country of breathtaking
beauty then it's a country that's never
been colonized less well known perhaps
is that for the past 25 years the nation
has struggled through a series of
domestic political skirmishes and
involving the longtime monarchy Maoist
rebels and elected politicians including
mr. dubas center-left Nepali Congress
party Nepal's central objective and mr.
DuBose has been to turn the page on this
persistent political instability so that
the nation may focus effectively on the
challenges that come with being one of
the poorest and least developed nations
in the world there is indeed evidence of
this occurring two years ago after an
extended process marked by protests
Nepal formally embraced a new
constitution to a remarkable degree the
Prime Minister's personal journey has
mirrored his nation's struggle to
achieve a functioning and stable
democracy this is the fourth time he has
held the office of Prime Minister the
previous terms occurring during the
tumultuous years of Nepal's decade-long
Civil War the journey has been a
difficult one both for mr. dooba and for
Nepal requiring no small amount of
resilience and hope over many decades
mr. dubaye was born and raised in a
remote region in the far west of Nepal
he studied political science
the humanities in Nepal and there was a
research fellow at the London School of
Economics throughout his career he has
worked to increase the political
participation of ethnic minorities women
rural citizens and other marginalized
Nepalese tonight's address by the Prime
Minister will shed light on Nepal's
efforts to chart a course to a brighter
future
please join me in welcoming the prime
minister of Nepal sure bahador dooba
[Applause]
don't see by lingas president of
Columbia University distinguished
professors faculty researchers core the
skull of students Friends of Nepal
ladies and gentlemen I feel honored to
be back here at this distinguished
center of learning and speak to this
gathering ability divisions
students and Friends of Nepal I express
my sincere gratitude to you mr.
president for the invitation I feel that
this forum is has got I feel that this
forum has contributed
cross-fertilization of knowledge and
exchange of perspective on several
contemporary issues of vital importance
[Applause]
so sorry she said
mr. president today I stand here to
highlight the borderless tree of
innocent who says sterile for over half
a century for democracy it is story of
people in an economically least
developed country remaining steadfast in
their commitment to democratic values
rule of law under the most difficult
circumstances and wide widespread
poverty the stories about the power and
promises of the dialogue and negotiation
in resolving the armed conflict it is
also about how deliberative process
creates conditions for enlightened
reasoning indecision of competing ideas
and opinions the stories about enriching
diversity through social cohesion and if
give citizenship the story of the
external by the people of Nepal under
the most difficult circumstances
demonstrate the depth of the earth
commitment to democracy and he means
example the to the contemporary world
having devoted my entire life and energy
to the struggle of democracy to the
struggle for democracy in Nepal having
been jailed for nine long years of my
political belief and ideology and having
having been removed from the base da
legitimately elected position of Prime
Minister twice by an autocratic King I
consider the Nepal's to look at external
weight by the hundreds of thousands of
my fellow capitate under the most
difficult circumstances remains
exemplary for the contemporary world
ladies and gentlemen the pulse trials
with democracy begin in 1950 the popular
movement led by the political party to
which I belong demolished what are the
four es don't panic Akira new regime
heralding a new dawn of democracy
unfortunately the young sprout of
democracy was nipped in the bud by the
ambitious monarch who jailed the post
democratically democratically elected
prime minister BB queer ala disband
democratic government people
degenerative institutions and outlaw the
political parties in 1960 democracy
suffered a brutal blow in Nepal
however the struggle for democracy never
subsides the people of Nepal never lost
their hope with my party in a polygamous
in the forefront the democratic struggle
continued under difficult circumstances
and context with three that gets up
ultimate sacrifice with restored
parliamentary system of democracy in
1990 with the response of democracy
Nepal impressed economic liberalisation
and open its market economy grew grew
faster the divided the dividend the
democracy was evident in a point to
economic growth in 2009 nineteen ninety
three ninety four hundred elected
government however soon after democratic
journey and then into difficult course
by eternal conflict and lasted for
decades
aggravating the difficulty difficulty
the new king instead of engaging with
democratic political forces
displayed his information towards
monarchy
and poster nation to another phase of
disciplined uncertainty against this
background underground arms they will
join the menacing political parties to
lunch a people's a moment against an
autocratic banoffee the movement
compelled the King yield to the people's
power the piece of art was signed
between the government and mouse level
in 2006 formally indeed armed conflict
enjoying the peaceful constitutional
politics we have participated in our
election also headed the government in
DiPaola canvas but voted for inclusive
education assembly to draft a democratic
constitution assembly deteriorate Nepal
as a Federal Democratic Republic ending
2002 ending to until 40 years
a world in Susa monarchy the second
castle assembly promulgated a democratic
and inclusive Constitution the written
by the people's has presented the
presentative
acceptable 2015 the lead the gang back
document but only concludes the peace
process and institutionalized inclusive
Federal Democratic Republic in Japan but
also marks the beginning of a new era of
peace stability and development the
Constitution accommodate aspirations of
all communities and ethnic groups it
embeds in it
the 31 fundamental rights of all people
including popular sovereignty the
consistency provides all independent
judiciary it provides powerful
collisional Commission's to promote and
protect rights and interests
of history see two women but it and
unlock desert builds communities I'm
happy to share with the distinguished
audience that one third of women
representation is ensured in the federal
and provincial Parliament and 40% of the
local government through the
constitutional provisions earlier this
week Nepal successfully concluded the
third and last phase of local level
elections with overwhelming
participation of all the political
parties through these elections held for
the first time in 20 years
Nepal is creating a local leadership
with democratic institutions the
representing the legitimate interest of
people we hope to build a future with
the same from the grassroots the essence
of Nepal's democracy is inclusive
inclusive political social and
development process we are preparing for
elections national and provincial
Parliament as mandated by the
Constitution it is my firm belief that
political freedoms and developmental
coupled mentality complementary
political transformation can hardly
sustain without economic transformation
and economy development is hardly
conclusive with our peoples involvement
and development process we want to meet
to make people feel that develop
development is a part of their life and
liberty
Nepal's combination is Yin we have
abundant natural resources we look to
enhance support and cooperation from the
international community to promote
investment and create jobs
our strategy locations between India and
China also provide an opportunity to
make the best use
of their glorious and happy developments
distinguished friends the world
confronted more complex and polarized
environment economic and financial
crisis has created a new security and
economic situation for geopolitical
competition
the rise of Cataclysm and tied up
violent religious extremism is turning
such society internet the rights of
ethnic politics is eroding core
principle that bind us together we must
find common ground and practice
tolerance and harmony to protect core
values of every culture and confront the
real problems steeped friends the
reality of Nepal is prism Nepal's
nations tent is heard compositive
culture remarkable residents of its
people
Nepal pursue political pluralism at home
and multiple on the international
missions the wisest thought for Humanity
has emanated from the insightful minds
of Nepal in the form of concessions
possible of peaceful coexistence the
political framework provides a path of
harmonious relations out of current
uncertainty and turbulence
regional cooperation is critical to the
building of trust and confidence of
Papi's progress and prosperity we
considered connectivity the project
widget for expanded cooperation creating
a win-win situation
Nepal is fiercely fiercely proud of its
historic individuals in partially
independent foreign policy
Nepal's does issue unsplit without fear
or favor our long study policy has been
to maintain friendship with all and work
for peace progress and prosperity Nepal
remains alert to concern and sensitivity
of its friends and expect them to be
sensitive to its concern as well we feel
the United Nations has a greater role
and responsibility in the chancel state
we must reform the United Nations to
make it more effective in responding
rapidly to global challenges the earth
friends would like to briefly talks
about the relations between Nepal and
Magnus State the latest state size among
the first few countries to establish
diplomatic relations with Nepal in the
1940s
our lesson had remained cordial and
cooperative marked by the mutual
interests and understanding the US has
supported the pal for democracy we take
this nation for its continued support
for the socio-economic development of
Nepal through varieties of measures we
are encouraged by the inclusion of Nepal
inclusion of Nepal in the million
Millennium Challenge corporation the 500
million MCC grant is the largest grant
he was received by Nepal covering energy
and transport it will it will greatly
help to harvestable hydro potentials and
generate thousands of megawatts of extra
energy it will contribute to the
mitigation and mitigation of climate
scenes while fostering green growth
people-to-people contact our dynamic
dimension for Nepal uses lessons the
u.s. continued to be the most preferred
destination for Nepalese students for
their higher education the academic
automatic the academic records they got
these resource additional 90 American
universities like yours have attracted
our building minds
similarly the American visiting Nepal on
academicians for tourism and his
development workers and volunteers
notably contributed to its a
socio-economic development such exists
exchanges dictate the strong bridge
between our countries and people before
I could let me express my desire to
promote greater collaboration and
cooperation between Columbia University
and universities in Nepal for
undertaking research area common
interest the academic exchange
contribute the sharing of ideas and
perspective and enriching the inside
understanding I know there are several
leaders in making in the audience I
would love to hear from their experience
and to listen their perspective
with this note I would like to thank
once again mr. Lizzie by lenders the
president of Columbia University faculty
members friends the people all male
students and the entire diversity family
for receiving us so Hardy for listening
to me with such a keen interest in
making all arrangement for today thank
you
because nothing let's watch something
deeper
[Applause]
thank you so much Prime Minister doba
it's an honor to have you here I
understand this is actually your second
time here so welcome back to Columbia
University it's now time for our
question and answer session so if you
would like to ask a question please
stand behind one of the two microphones
I'll be taking questions from both of
them you can do that right now as I
speak in fact I encourage you to stand
up and do so I'll be taking questions
from both sides is the student who we
selected from the undergraduate
Committee on global thought here to ask
the first question
wonderful so then our first question
will be from a member of our
undergraduate Committee on global
thought if everyone could please begin
by stating their name and the school
that they study at or an other other
affiliation and then go ahead and ask
hello my name is Yasmin I'm a freshman
at Columbia College thank you very much
for your speech I was wondering what
advice would you give to world leaders
to make the world safer and more unified
I was wondering what advice you would
give to world leaders to make the world
more safe and unified oh it is a
question why I did read with the answer
but I think the leaders will discuss
talk and to find this solution
individually thank you this side please
on my right hello my name is rickety I'm
from Nepal and I'm a journalism student
here at the Graduate School of
Journalism first of all I would like to
congratulate your government for holding
the third phase of Elections my question
is how does your government look forward
to resolving the crisis in my days
that's been going on for a word two
years since the new constitution was
promulgated and also since you talks a
lot about good governance how do you
defend the largest cabinet that you have
right now in Nepal in
define politics first of all I would
like to answer about the cabinet members
you know according to the constitution
10% 10% of its total number can can
become ministers therefore 60 Minister
can succeed Minister is the 6600 in a
mother of the assembly 1660 the mother
of the cabinet is is it's according to
the Constitution but still the smaller
number we know because regarding your
regarding a question about issue
Apogee's we in terms of dialogue we try
to accommodate there some of the
legitimate demand by a mainly the
Constitution but unfortunately you
couldn't pass the past I've been made
because we need 2/3 of majority to pass
the cuts in soon before we couldn't pass
them and would like we try to
accommodate the Islamic demands but I
think they realized and we hope they
participated in the local mission I
think the answer on send position right
now in future repulse is very flexible
it can be reformed according to the
wishes of the people thank you very much
thank you
hello sir thank you for being here my
name is Kevin I'm a graduate student in
the history department I have a question
for you as the leader of a country who
went through a natural disaster a few
years ago what is some advice you have
for international organizations or the
international world community regarding
responses to natural disasters happening
right now yes thank you very much
funnier
consolable that will disaster because in
the palace witnessed devastating
earthquake machine Li and firstly still
too few months ago with the devastating
flood in the southern part in the panel
but regarding earthquake what is it easy
to find the solution in the nobody knows
when it happens we have to have a
preparedness they are foldable is very
much aware of where we are now we can
cope a future the preparedness is
necessary therefore now we can we can we
can multiple disaster then we can we
have prepared we can mitigate disasters
you know what about the flood it's you
know inundation therefore we have played
with some some plan so that in future
this kind of can happen in future
because of the inundation in the
southern part of Nepal and the flood
there are many would be opinions about
the Hawaii flux why this kind of
disaster occurs therefore we have to
have a some long-term policy so that you
know in all this and cannot happen at
the same time for that can be mitigated
by having a right building storage in
the hill areas so they during the
monsoon what can be cultural and can can
be floor to irrigation as well
and it's under casino we depart cannot
cope with the climate change you know
unfortunately nowadays greenhouse effect
is there DiPaola world cannot cope with
this problem as a whole and united
nation and university can can create its
opinion so that greenhouse emissions can
be controlled thank you thank you
hi my name is Erica new Pawnee
I'm in my first year at Columbia
undergraduate engineering school and my
question is this as a Nepali I've seen
many in Nepal and discriminate against
those that they do not consider Nepali
how do you plan to change the societal
knows attitude and promote the idea that
all people in Nepali Nepali not just
specific are people of specific
backgrounds there's no I don't think
there's any discrimination
please know towards my de Medicis people
in Nepal I think do not completely
accept that people of all backgrounds in
Nepali no no ladies but citizens they
have you they have so many cities of
this we don't have such yes there are
some problems with but we have to solve
to resolve these problems you know
still we have untouchable jail facility
in some areas still there are some caste
system is there but we have to we have
to eradicate this kind of
things about this packing time they will
be so earnest so sure programmers should
be introduced in the bath from it now
there is not much about the despair and
disparity is high Prime Minister thank
you so much for your speech my name is
Anushka Von D I'm a senior at Columbia
College studying comparative literature
my question was actually about the
rights of the LGBT community in Nepal
Nepal has been a world leader in LGBT
rights particularly in South Asia in
2007 the Nepalese Supreme Court
decriminalized homosexuality in 2015
your constitution had specific
provisions for anti-discrimination
policies against members of the LGBT
community for which I don't think the
country is given enough credit my
question was in the two years since what
an jebel measures is your government
taken to ensure that the rights of the
community are protected and that
benefits are extended to them in forms
of health care
specialized counseling needs or any
other facilities that might be necessary
yes to concision it already but it could
right but again we have to have
awareness we have to have total
awareness we have to have a some sort of
education you know we have to we have to
to change the mind is not easy
and for anybody some area this economy
the country but the values fasts one can
say maybe fast to uncool are the other
adaptability room before the body's most
content country on this issue again
hi my name is Avinash triple Kumar and
I'm a master student in mechanical
engineering thank you for being here mr.
prime minister so I was wondering
considering that some smaller developing
nations have seen significant levels of
foreign direct investment as a result of
their intellectual property policies how
does Nepal plan to move forward with
their intellectual property policies
specifically concerning patents and
trademarks for developing technologies
now we guaranteed it looks a property
right we have a strong loan they said we
are also planning to to have more work
reform on this issue and I don't think
there's any problems will guarantee the
people who wants to have a property
right right
[Applause]
Thank You of next hello I'm George a
junior in Columbia College thank you for
being here today
my question is what are your thoughts
and feelings regarding the young
Nepalese man that travel to the UK every
year to serve as part of the Gurkhas and
the British Army yes nipple easy and
wise the superevil helped design the
boots but army and because the part yes
you know the proper job everywhere job
seekers have the earth but the please
avoid a claim like prepare to be the
part of with skorca Abbey we have a
treaty between United Kingdom and the
power that we there is a treaty allow
our double is wise to even if they do I
want to try that with sabe
[Applause]
namaste my name is Vivek Krishna I'm
from India and I am a first year medical
student here at Columbia my question for
you is about the health care system in
Nepal I am curious to know whether the
government is moving more towards a
socialized model of health care and how
it plans to kind of ensure or cover many
of the citizens of Nepal because I
understand currently coverage is minimal
and costs are high as a collectible
fortunately though we have brought
mental health care yeah we know doctors
want to go to the really deals in the
palaver even if there are hospitals we
don't have bus doctors to do we have to
go we have opened many medical colleges
where they can study and produce more
doctors they prepare to to go to the UK
to the US Europe you know they don't
want to work in the early years but
nowadays they have realised and so we
have a every district we have a 75d
streets now we have 766 the hospital
said still we have a limited number of
doctors the shortcoming of doctors we
form a middle college yet we produce
doctors easily we have probably know I
think inclusive in 10 years time there
will be health care in every household
thank you
I thank you very much Prime Minister Zhu
before coming and speaking today I'm
Sarah I am a senior in Columbia College
sitting English literature and ecology
evolution and Environmental Biology and
in some of you studies environmental
biology and especially with you know the
beautiful landscape in Nepal I was
wondering what do you receive for the
conservation efforts for sustainable
development especially in such a
critical time for the next few decades
to come and also as a not so political
question who is your favorite Nepali
artist thank you oh if I've been someone
in other would-be agree with me you know
good practices I like them can you
repeat your first question so I was
wondering in regards to sustainable
development and conservation efforts in
a conservation they were just where they
still probably know that nobody care
about environment still it forest
conservation maybe aliens of animals in
the forest the air box still we have to
do but 0i illegal poaching is there
amenities now we are planning to protect
our land and forests and animals
hi my name is Rita mio pani I am a
graduate student in the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences I am from Kathmandu
Nepal my question is about citizenship
in our current constitution so many
commentators have pointed out that our
Constitution as of right now is sexist
and against and discriminates against
women for example under Article 11.7 a
child who's born to a Nepali woman
married to a foreigner can only get it
can only get citizenship can only get a
naturalized citizenship he or she cannot
get a citizenship by descent when the
law of the land the Constitution
discriminates against women in this and
other ways how how can you know you
claim to be inclusive in Nepal you know
I mean anyway girls women the married to
the police immediately they get she
Geneva but India in India if the police
dog marry to India she has to wait for
for seven years but Nepal Indian girls
came upon this and so I'm talking about
children of Nepali women who marry
foreigners how come they are only
entitled to naturalized citizenship
whereas foreigners who nip who marry
Nepali men and have children those
children get citizenship by descent
there's a double standard there's a
constitution and as far as I know you
neither you nor your cabinet has come
out for or against these issues I agree
with you there is some disabilities I
agree with you but still very wise in
favor of what you said maybe in future
we can
before the Constitution I agree with you
it would have to our policies I
personally favor what you said but I
couldn't even have you considered coming
out for or against these articles I love
you what do you say any noise okay thank
you thank you next question my name is
Joseph bear I'm a freshman in the school
of general studies so as you probably
know Nepal is at a very interesting
crossroads historically it's been in a
interesting location it's between two
very large emerging superpowers India
and China it's been part of the
non-alignment movement and it's found
favor in both the east and the west so
my question is as a country becomes a
economically developing state and it
enters the next generation of statehood
does do you feel that there is more of
an incline to align with a Western
economic focus or an eastern economic
focus is it more of the global market or
is it more of the neighboring market
that you feel that Nepal is more
inclined towards we have pursued yep
completely to market economy therefore
we are for market economy but still we
need investment in the power wherever
hydro potential country natural beauties
welcome to these industries and the
hydropower potential country I'd write
about we welcome any investment in Nepal
I know I told you that we have pursued a
policy of upmarket economy but we did
investment without investment we cannot
we cannot develop our country promise
thank you
hello mr. prime minister my name is
Anjali I'm a freshman at Barnard College
and I'm of Indian origin and I wanted to
first congratulate your government on
passing a new law against the tradition
of choppity but what measures is your
government going to take to change the
attitude of the people towards this
custom and what more is going to be done
to protect the rights of women in Nepal
may I interject to ask you to explain
that for those who are not familiar with
the term in the audience thank you so
much hey Cho pithy I believe is where
women who are menstruating during the
time of their menstruation period they
have to be sent out side of their houses
and they have to stay in huts and for
the remainder of their period they have
to stay in their huts and only when
they're done with their period can they
come back into their houses yes still
the practices kind of inhuman and
illegal
maybe but legally they are not allowed
nobody can allow women to to have a do
the mystery sometimes with table
machines you'll be exempt diving out
from the horse no but maybe some
practices maybe if you're all illegal
then but what measures is your
government going to take them if it is
I'm going to change the attitude of the
people yes unfortunately we have to
educate the society if they do you think
masses might very few any other wise
things you know this these are improving
this okay thank you so much sir can you
just come a little bit closer to the
microphone oh yeah thank you so much mr.
prime minister thank you for the great
speech I'm a senior at yes majoring in
sociology I'm particularly interested in
the foreign policy of Nepal it's known
that both China and India have been
courting Nepal in recent years why only
PO has has been taking rather new
for stances on range of issues for
example the recent standoff between
Indians and Chinese in da clamp so my
question is yeah I'm wondering Cooney
pole maintain its neutrality and not
choose a site in new near future because
China has been more ambitious than India
in recent years in terms in terms of
financial investment and aid to in pole
but like what India offered is Toft by
what China has delivered so far so my
question is what's your philosophy of
dealing with these two giants look the
pulse of holy policy is dictated by
geopolitical reality in the past
national interests is to reboot listen
with both the countries India and China
it is in the interest of Nepal we're
very good relations with India were very
good listen to China we want we want to
maintain good listen Sarah regarded
Brooklyn and the first question is India
China to resolve this issue through
direct negotiations what they are doing
right now
hello mr. prime minister thank you so
much for your speech my name is Rehan
I'm from the Teachers College I have an
extension to the question that was just
asked what is Nepal stands in terms of
foreign policy not only with India and
China but the broader Sark nations that
it is surrounded by right and in terms
of how you would foresee the next few
years in terms of foreign policy as I
told you about the portable Shimla
father were very good listen with South
India and China and regarding security
is in Kathmandu ago
therefore we went to strengthen sack
thank you for our next question can we
get an interpreter please wait we'll
wait for the interpreter to come to the
microphone please
thank you hello good afternoon I'm very
happy to see you here this is the first
time I'm seeing you here at Columbia
University I'm curious I wanted to know
two things in Nepal in colleges when
we're talking about deaf children and
getting educated there hasn't been a lot
of Education for deaf students and
colleges so we do see advancements for
other students but not for deaf students
and second I want to talk about
interpreters in Nepal there are not many
interpreters because the government is
not willing to pay for interpreters so
there aren't many interpreters that are
available but then we have a problem
with deaf people being able to
communicate especially when they go to
medical appointments and they want to
speak to their doctors what happens as a
consequence is that many die and don't
get proper medical care so I wanted to
ask about those two things education and
medical care for the deaf and one more
thing I'd like to add my name is Ravina
Ravindra Rabindra and I'm from Nepal I
came here and now I am studying
technology in at City College
I am delighted to see a Nepalese why who
studied Nepal came to UK you may be
aware that we have a the schools there
where we relate to Nepal television
where us interpreters and announcer in
televisions the English program also we
have a new button firstly still there
are small number of the people who are
studying in the school's the school's
definitely as you said in the in the in
the hospitals we need interpreters
definitely it's very pertinent question
you raised I would look at this matter
we have after I didn't care for do and
they did is to and that the people who
is there should be given interpret
interpreter in the hospital I would look
into
namaste my name's Alice I'm a master's
student in political science and a PhD
student in psychology from Stanford
University I'm a survivor of the Napoli
earthquake and then I worked in neva
after the during the relief work and as
psychologists we turn to believe that
mental health is very important but I'm
really just wondering for Napoli people
will you prioritize economic development
over you know other need for happiness
or for belonging or how do you balance
how do you kind of navigate limited
resources to take care of mental health
and physical health
thank you very much survey but it's
important in part it ain't personal you
know
fortunately Nepalese people are so brave
you know
as if they they are coping this problem
that happened you know they are very
brave people you know they forget
everything the trauma this is not Roma
very very few areas then you could we
have bravely faced the situation you
know now we have to have we have to have
a some sort of education awareness type
program so that the buildings the roads
we have to now we are educating people
that we have to be very much aware in
future if in the earthquake we have to
have sustained buildings houses and
other things in schools I think in
future nobody knows when the
happen but in future people will cope
with this with the problem immediately
with bravely and we have Crimea now have
a wellness program education program at
the same time people are very much
receptive for work because the
constructing new buildings new houses
they are famous obviously this should be
they should have builded which should be
constructed
people are already know this I think the
future even if society happens there
will some cook - casualty there will be
few trauma Prime Minister my name is
richer and I'm a student of I'm a
student at Teachers College and studying
conflict and power so my question is
actually more from a standpoint of
learning rather than asking about the
political issues I want to understand
how Nepal as a country managers the
power relation between and being you
know having India and China as neighbors
- very big power centers
how does Nepal manage to have its own
identity and say in innum issues thank
you very much for a parting question you
know you may be awarded Nepal has never
been colonized we had a very good lease
you did you do this also you know I read
a very good list in China and India both
Island and Friends of the palette they
understand our position
as I told it before the past fantasies
to have a good list with them we put
them the Indian so supporting the pants
development program fine either some
supporting development problems and we
are happiness but they also sign I'm
Indian so the limitation hi my name is
Gerren Salman I'm doing research at
Columbia University Medical Center and
my question is very general I just
wanted to know what Nepal is doing to
help the Rohingya Muslims in Myanmar oh
look we are facing the refugee problem
still very she was no Portuguese disease
I'm here we can't afford more if you
need me but unfortunately it was just
pure a few ringers and so are the
nopales welcome you know
where we live it is where prongs you
know we are facing we're facing the
reason if you probably know we cannot we
cannot small country you know we cannot
have him war burden but I think man
Margo Bennett SoCal
thank you hi I'm Trish T I'm a graduate
students at Teachers College my question
to you is what measures is your
government taking to address that
achieve the to address the achievement
gap between the public and private
school systems in the power yes we are
we allow private schools and public
schools you know but as you said is not
easy to balance yes but every period
they was boy has got to st. good schools
but it depends upon the their income
income
the ability to pay you know therefore in
the palace nowadays whenever the parents
are even be able to send their children
in good schools world English school
English school they are attracting these
government allocated any resources for
the development of whoever it is Weber
health care education is the priority of
our government we expect more money
these idiots
thank you well we only have time for one
more question so you have the honor of
being the last question I apologize to
those of you who are standing in line
I study sustainability management here
at Columbia there's a lot of social
environmental issues but every store ISM
there's a lot of trash they still six
people died trying to climb the Everest
there's a lot of fun I was wondering if
your government is trying to have any
ecotourism measures in place similar to
what Costa Rica does to protect the
natural integrity of the natural
resources in the country in specific
areas tourism
now this to disturb poly tourists our
topic today pal and we are good hotels
and good rules even in the Himalayan
areas and so are coming to the valley
and we welcome them there is no problem
I love this um there was a lot of trash
this year and the trash was never
removed from Mount Everest a lot of
charge rates of the local community that
serves these tourists we have to the
government should raise the money to to
clean yes to trash in this to the Buddha
test but also I'll firstly we don't know
but we have to get the timer sighs well
you know this will appeal thank you so
much Prime Minister Doba thank you for
taking the time to speak with us today
and especially thank you for taking the
time to address so many questions from
the audience
you're welcome if you there's there
anything else you'd like to say thank
you for your good questions I have a
very bad person to our trance on the
questions you know sorry you forgive me
there's nothing to appreciate police
ramrez edition along with plants and
inclusion
I just wanted to add I'm from the United
States that I've had the privilege of
spending a great deal of time in Nepal
over the past 15 years and so listening
to you speak and especially during the
question and answer session I was really
struck by how the themes that were
touched on both by yourself and by our
students and other community members
here were specific to Nepal and yet
really go far beyond Nepal those are
questions from the question of how to
achieve both legal and social equality
for all persons residing within a
country - how to balance environmental
sustainability with economic development
those are certainly questions that face
Nepal there are also questions that face
the United States and I daresay the rest
of the world so we appreciate you taking
the time to share the the unique
perspective that Nepal has on dealing
with these issues thank you so much for
your time and for honoring us with your
presence
[Applause]